so let's talk for a second about where
we are now in 2021 you know i was i
believe 17 years old in uh in 2001 and
it's been half a generation uh a huge
number of americans not only don't
remember 9 11 they weren't live for 9
11. and so there seems to be this sort
of counterfactual assumption that no
matter what we did post 9 11 we were
bound not to have another terror attack
and because there was no further severe
terror attack on american soil a
spectacular attack like 911 there's an
assumption that no matter what we did it
was never going to happen and we may
very well see the results of that sort
of thinking in exactly the same way that
we saw the results that sort of thinking
on 9 11 given the fact that you have the
president of the united states right now
saying that al qaeda was not in
afghanistan and we had routed them out
they are right back in afghanistan the
haqqani network which is al-qaeda
associated was helping to quote-unquote
handle security at at the kabul
international airport and you have isis
which is obviously extraordinarily
active over there are we experiencing a
similar national failure of imagination
like we saw in the late 90s
we certainly are are experiencing some
forgetfulness about what happened on
september 11th and what transpired after
it uh you know i hear a lot about the
mistakes that we made that the obama
administration made the trump
administration made uh yeah in 20 years
we made some mistakes but in an
enterprise this tough this difficult you
were going to make some mistakes
what we did achieve though was a despite
all of mistakes beside missteps
maybe there were other ways to do things
but we achieved what i did not think
possible on september 12th which was
not another attack
it was so frightening after 9 11. we had
we had streams of intelligence talking
about radiological attacks on washington
d.c smallpox attacks on the country
constant
threats of another attack it really
wasn't until we captured khalid sheikh
mohammed who was the 911 planner he was
the sort of field general
for uh for
north america
that we had a sense of what they might
have been planning and were able to
begin to act on it it wasn't until we
were able to take out some of these
nests to
to work with the world actually to
trace their their financing in ways that
led us to some of their people and so
what this bought us was an opportunity
to really do the hard work of
counterterrorism i remember ben on at
the president's speech to the congress
the joint session of congress he said
that this fight on terrorism will long
will be
in place long after i'm gone and many of
my successors
and we lost patience because perhaps we
forgot what it was like on september
12th and 13th and 14th when it was
terrifying to go onto an airplane when
it was terrifying to go into the center
of new york city when we worried that
the anthrax attacks were actually
foreign attacks
yes i think we have a bit of amnesia and
i can't blame uh you know my students
here at stanford who
weren't even conscious on september 11th
but i surely don't understand how those
who were in the congress in the senate
those who were in positions of authority
at that time how they've forgotten that
i can't that i can't forgive so
secretary rice let's talk about some of
the other geostrategic implications of
what just happened in afghanistan
because obviously one major geostrategic
implication is the rise of jihadism
basically everywhere i mean osama bin
laden said in the run up to 911 that he
thought that america was a paper tiger
certainly that impression seems to be uh
taking root across the g hottest world
uh the iranians have been getting very
aggressive in their talk about
developing a nuclear weapon
and and obviously terror groups have
already seeped back into afghanistan and
there there's a rally this week with
with members of jihadist groups holding
a mock funeral for the united states
complete with with fake coffins um but
there's also some major geostrategic
implications for china and russia
despite the state department's uh
newfound enthusiasm for
large-scale letter sending to the
taliban they said they've gotten over
100 countries to sign a letter to the
taliban urging them to allow people to
leave china and russia were not on that
list of countries the u.n security
council resolution that called for
freedom of movement from afghanistan did
not include china did not include russia
both abstained china is already
obviously on the way toward recognizing
the taliban as the legitimate regime in
afghanistan which by the way is a major
shift from 96 to 2001 when only three
countries on planet earth actually
recognize the taliban as a regime saudi
arabia uae and pakistan now you have
major regimes that are going to do so
probably including the united states
given that we have to bribe them to get
people out the russians continue to to
nurture their relationship with the
taliban and you know as far as other
countries it would be astonishing to me
if the russians don't look with envious
eyes of latvia and estonia and the
chinese don't look at taiwan and say to
themselves
what exactly are our limits here
well credibility is not divisible uh you
can't
lose credibility in one place and
maintain it in other places because
people look at the totality
of what you've become and um no i think
we should remember that in the the
run-up to 911
al-qaeda got bolder and bolder first
there was the attack on the world trade
center uh in new york and then there was
the attack on our embassies and in 1998
in tanzania and kenya then there was the
attack on the coal and then there was
the attack of 9 11. uh each time we
didn't respond they got bolder and so i
expect that the jihadist movement will
be now quite bold uh one thing that we
used to to think and was that we had to
have an alternative we had to show
people that this wasn't the only way uh
now they're going to be able to crow for
some time that they've defeated a major
power and they will attract and they
will recruit on that basis so that's the
first problem the second problem is
actually with our allies i'll come to
china and russia but i'm i'm as
concerned uh that our allies
who apparently weren't really consulted
properly but most importantly had signed
on to this 20-year war
are now wondering about us and it's
going to take some work to rebuild those
relationships and you can't just do it
with words
i'm a i'm a former diplomat i believe in
diplomacy but when it comes to
some of the challenges out there
where we have bad actors that might try
to exploit it's going to require
some action too so i hope that we're
thinking of ways to send a strong
message about taiwan because the chinese
will wonder if we weren't willing to
sustain a presence in afghanistan given
all of the blood and treasure given the
fact that that was where the attack came
from in 9 11 are we really going to
to help taiwan defend itself as we have
said under the taiwan relations act if
you're in ukraine today
are you really
believing that if vladimir putin decides
he's going to be more aggressive in
eastern ukraine or maybe even start to
move that line westward is the united
states really going to respond when it
wouldn't stay in afghanistan given all
that afghanistan meant to us and for
iran
what will it mean to them
about what we're willing to do to defend
our friends and allies from uh iranian
groups in iraq or yemen or other places
so
we need some action
i would probably start with taiwan and
that probably means maybe
another robust arms package to taiwan or
some demonstration that the united
states is
good to its word because our credibility
has taken a hit and
we just have to understand that and and
move on from there
thank you for tuning in to the daily
wire one of the fastest growing
conservative media outlets in the
country if you enjoyed this video be
sure to give it a like and subscribe to
our youtube channel so you don't miss
out on any of our content